the women that you date and have data  are they controlling  now i do date women exclusively but i'm  how did you know that i date women it's  possible i date men or both right  well that is possible but i wouldn't  assume that i didn't assume that yeah  i'll let you tell me do you date men too  exclusively women oh  would it be a bad thing for our  conversation if i dated men well it  wouldn't be bad for our conversation it  would be interesting okay  why don't you date men i'm not attracted  to men oh  um  i don't see anything wrong with it but i  know you do you do not see anything  wrong with it with being attracted to  men why not  why why would it be wrong uh because  it's of the same sex so it's abnormal  but that's not an argument  there's a fact what makes something  normal let me ask you this um